das ende des autos so wie wir es kennen
denn so wie es sich im moment als
blechlawine vor allem durch unsere
städte welt so ist es nicht mehr tragbar
während den hoch zeiten der pandemie
haben wir bereits einen blick in die
zukunft werfen können weniger verkehr
und ruhige sehr ruhige innenstädte und
genau daran arbeiten verkehrsplaner und
planerin auf der ganzen welt eine
vollkommen neue welt der mobilität mit
viel weniger autos vor allem in den
innenstädten und radwege der zukunft
werden als bananen und pommes frites
tüten gebaut wir freuen uns dieses thema
von pm mit exklusivem material aus dem
aktuellen heft übernehmen zu können in
zusammenarbeit mit dem magazin gibt es
übrigens auch noch ein hammer
gewinnspiel bei dem er ein bresser messe
teleskop gewinnen könnt hammer teil also
los geht's
haben sich willkommen und einen riesen
dank an pm für die umfangreiche
recherche die wir so gar nicht hätten
leisten können das magazin pm und unser
kanal klicks ums haus im schicken
nämlich sehr ähnlich zum einen sind wir
von wissenschaft und wissen total
begeistert und zum anderen finden wir
kaum etwas wichtiger als gute recherche
wahrheit und fakten für diejenigen die
es nicht mehr abwarten können der link
zum glühen schrieb ist schon mal hier
und wenn man sich da weiter klickt kommt
man auch zu den genauen
teilnahmebedingungen mein eigener
versuch an der zukunft der mobilität
teilzunehmen endete in einem
bürokratiemonster ich wollte nicht mehr
und nicht weniger als man auto mit
anderen zu teilen denn fahrzeuge die nur
einer familie oder noch schlimmer nur
einer person gehören sind einfach ein
immenses platzproblem 95 prozent der
zeit stehen sie herum und bei fünf
prozent werden sie genutzt und legen in
der stadt auch nur kleine strecken
zurück eine absolute
ressourcenverschwendung deswegen wollte
ich mein elektroauto teilen dafür
braucht man eine spezielle versicherung
die das ermöglicht doch will man sein
fahrzeug damit anmelden dann wird eine
gewerbeanmeldung verlangt und das zog
dann einen rattenschwanz hinter sich her
denn dann muss man auch ein betrieb beim
finanzamt anmelden die
berufsgenossenschaft mail sich man muss
mitglied in der industrie und
handelskammer werden und so weiter und
plötzlich ist man für die deutsche
bürokratie ein unternehmer obwohl man
eigentlich nur das sinnvollste machen
dass es mit einem pkw gibt ihn zu teilen
meint es ist dafür vorbereitet und in
der zukunft soll es ganz einfach mit der
app möglich sein das fahrzeug für jeden
und jede freizugeben und dann später
soll es auch autonom als obwohl taxi
fahren können und damit sind wir in der
zukunft der städte mit weniger autos und
einer komplett veränderten mobilität
denn so wie heute geht es nicht mehr
weiter und macht auch gar keinen sinn
direkt bei mir vor der haustür da
beginnt die neue mobilität gestartet mit
popup radwegen sind hier neue breite
radwege angelegt worden und die sind
nicht nur breit sondern auch endlich gut
vor dem zu parken geschützt worden es
wurde auch wirklich zeit schnell wege
schnellstraßen für fahrräder wird es in
zukunft in berlin geben usw das fahrrad
wird in berlin eine vollkommen neue
rolle spielen berlin ist hier vorreiter
bei der neuen mobilität und der
radverkehr ist nur eines von vielen
beispielen das auto hat in innenstädten
zumindest so wie es bisher genutzt wurde
ausgedient denn die umstellung auf die e
mobilität ist nur ein baustein der
energie- und verkehrswende die dringend
nötig ist und das bremsen des
klimawandels ist hier nur ein positiver
nebenaspekt diese entwicklung in der eu
verursacht der verkehr rund 30 prozent
der gesamten co2 emissionen rund 60
prozent davon entfallen auf das auto
während der ausstoß in der industrie
beim bohnen oder bei der
energieerzeugung seit jahren sinkt
steigen die verkehrsbedingten co2
emissionen dazu kommt bis zum jahr 2050
werden zwei drittel der weltbevölkerung
in städten leben mehr als sechs
milliarden menschen schon heute echt
sind die metropolen unter der last des
verkehrs machen enge lärm und abgase den
stadtbewohnern das leben schwer unnötig
schwer denn längst gibt es konzepte für
nachhaltige mobilität und dabei wird es
nicht die eine lösung sein sondern für
jede stadt ein ganz spezielles konzept
das auf die besonderheiten rücksicht
nimmt in la paz bolivien und in medellin
kolumbien überbrücken seilbahnen große
höhenunterschiede im stadtgebiet
barcelona hat begonnen komplette
stadtquartiere supermann zahn us für den
autoverkehr zu sperren auf den einstigen
straßenkreuzung treffen sich die
anwohner nun zu yoga klassen wenn die
luft weniger von abgasen verbessere so
haben umweltmediziner kalkuliert werden
in der region pro jahr 3500 menschen
weniger daran sterben übrigens gibt es
solche bereiche auch immer öfter hier in
berlin wie zum beispiel die
friedrichstraße eine ehemalige
hauptstraße und bis 2030 sollen in der
innenstadt keine verbrennung erfahren
der japanische autohersteller toyota
plant am fuß des vulkans fuji eine
komplett nachhaltige modellstadt rufen
city mit emissionsfreien
selbststeuernden fahrzeugen in singapur
experimentiert die stadtverwaltung mit
der vernetzung anonymisierter daten um
den verkehr der millionenmetropole
intelligent zu steuern singapur steht
damit an der spitze eines
internationalen rankings zur zukunfts
bereitschaft für urbane mobilität
amsterdam steht auf platz zwei berlin
auf platz zehn in dieser ball ist der
deutsche autohersteller volkswagen in
einem feldversuch busse mit hilfe von
quantencomputern effizienter durch den
verkehr steuern es geht also voran stadt
für stadt projekt für projekt und am
ende wird alles anders sein ein ganz
wichtiger treiber werden dafür apps und
daten seien schon heute gibt es sich
anbieter die ihre sharing angebote über
apps anbieten sammel taxis oder bright
polin funktionieren nur damit so
schwindet auch langsam die herkömmliche
verkehrszählung um mit immer mehr daten
kann auch der öffentliche
personennahverkehr
straßenbahn busse die u-bahn s-bahn und
so weiter immer besser ausgelastet
werden fahren viele menschen gibt es
mehr bahnen fahren weniger wird der takt
reduziert und für uns die nutzer
nutzerin wird die fortbewegung egal mit
welchem verkehrsmittel immer
komfortabler in berlin gibt es die app
shelby mit der ich auf nahezu alle
verkehrsmittel zugriff habe und mir das
beste aussuchen kann immer mehr berliner
nutzen wegen solcher angebote schon
heute immer weniger ihr eigenes auto bzw
sie haben gar keins mehr in städten wie
berlin macht das auch gar keinen sinn
weil man mit den öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln mit dem fahrrad roller
oder fahrrad sharing angeboten usw
sowieso schneller am ziel ist und kein
parkplatz benötigt das spart eine menge
geld und der stadt eine menge
umweltbelastung überhaupt ist dieser
verzicht da kann verzicht sondern eben
ein gewinn für alle wir haben es ja
jetzt alle wären corona gelernt und das
ist einer der vielen veränderungen wir
müssen gar nicht so mobil sein vieles
lässt sich im home office erledigen denn
das ist auch eines der verfahren unserer
mobilität zu verändern einfach weniger
mobil seien viele reisen sind vollkommen
überflüssig wir müssen nicht ständig von
a nach b fahren oder eben ein anderes
weniger umweltschädliches verkehrsmittel
ist vielleicht die bessere wahl und
damit geht dann die fortbewegung immer
besser namens adam wurden die
fahrradspuren jetzt mit spitz
zulaufenden pomm fritz typen wie sie
dort üblich sind und bananen angelegt in
kurven verbreitern sich die radwege wie
eine banane weil fahrräder dort mehr
platz benötigen und an ampeln sind die
spuren für die warten viel breiter weil
es sich dort bei rot ansonsten so
knüppelt und läuft danach wie eine
pommes tüte spitzt zu und so zeigt sich
auch hier dass eine verkehrs revolution
stück für stück im gange ist und wir in
zehn bis dreißig jahren unsere
innenstädte nicht mehr wiedererkennen
werden und jetzt gibt es dieses presse
im cx 102 goto teleskop eq zu gewinnen
mit einer hammer optik und einer
computer and box mit der könnt ihr jeden
stern jede galaxie oder himmelskörper
genau ansteuern der computer weiß wo was
genau ist außerdem gibt es obendrauf
auch noch zwei gratis ausgaben des
magazins pm inklusive der aktuellen
ausgabe dafür einfach hier gleich auf
den abo button für das magazin beenden
klicken kleiner geheimtipp die chancen
zu gewinnen sind ziemlich gut und in der
aktuellen ausgabe gibt es noch viel mehr
infos zur mobilität von morgen und noch
viele weitere super interessante themen
aus der wissenschaft und forschung zum
beispiel berichtet pm über die riesige
gefahr des weltraumschrotts knapp 30.000
teile fliegen wie gewehrkugeln durch den
weltraum und bedrohen satelliten und
menschen oder aber die amerikanischen
forschungsteams tornados jagen und im
wahrsten sinne des wortes wird es
spannend wenn es um die 5000 jahre alten
steintafeln mit dem gilgamesch epos geht
ich drücke euch auf jedenfalls die
daumen bis dann bleibt dran